[Musique]
donc on se retrouve pour la deuxième
partie l'entretien avec jean pierre
petit air une deuxième partie qui
n'était pas prévu qui va être un peu la
partie off puisque d'un commun accord on
s'est dit que ce serait intéressant de
prolonger la discussion sur la
philosophie c'est à dire partir de la
science partir de la cosmologie de votre
modèle janus pour voir ce qu'on pouvait
éventuellement en dire sur le plan
philosophique
autrement dit essaie de tenter l'union
de la physique et de la métaphysique
oui mais il ya une chose c'est que
l'onuci répond papier de la question
attention simplement je dirais que quand
vous parlez de philosophie de
métaphysique tout de suite je me
retourne vers le film 9 bizarre c'est
quoi la métaphysique aujourd'hui eh ben
c'est vrai que bon c'est un peu
compliqué de répondre à cette question
parce que la métaphysique aujourd'hui
deux à ma connaissance en tout cas là il
n'y a pas vraiment d'études ou de
recherche en métaphysique
actuellement il ya plutôt une
réactualisation des théories
philosophiques ancienne mais c'est très
difficile d'envisager une métaphysique
du 21e siècle une slr pour ça pour rien
vous cacher que je que j'ai voulu qu'on
fasse cet entretien parce que je me suis
dit que paradoxalement c'est peut-être
la science qui avait des éléments à nous
donner pour penser la métaphysique
aujourd'hui donc est-ce que le
scientifique peut du coup venir en aide
aux philosophes essayé de lui donner les
éléments d'inspiration pour créer de
nouvelles métaphysique
les scientifiques s'amuse beaucoup avec
ce genre de concept
ils se l'approprient pas là de dire
maintenant la lettre c'est nous qui sont
à même le définit alors c'est vrai quand
on a vu apparaître tafila mécanique
quantique c'est vraiment l'entourent
nous complète colloque le réel disparaît
derrière un écran de fumée quand c'est
incroyable on croit que c'est des
particules non ceux des zones pour que
nous on mange des particules ensuite
vous avez des paradoxes
vous avez des trucs temps qui passe par
deux fentes à la fois et la seule photo
vous avez une parade experts vous avez
des photos qui se disent bonjour alors
qu'il s'éloigne
deux fois la vitesse de la lumière étude
a donc ça permet de jouer énormément
avec ce caractère déconcertant ça donne
d'excellents films science fiction est
donc plutôt qu'autre chose sa dalle des
grands discours et qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire de tout ça alors le modèle janus
est intéressant parce qu'il apporte une
sorte de réponse à tout ça bon
d'ailleurs vous commencez à voir dans le
nouvel observateur de janvier que des
scientifiques en dise qu'il y a deux
univers qui ont du temps qui vont à
l'envers et ça le premier un type qui a
dit ça c'est sakharov
qu'est ce que c'est des mondes qui ont
des flèches du temps opposé mer
magnifique d'un truc comme ça alors en
plus on rajoute au mieux tout ça cet
objet qui est big board
on lui donne toutes les formes le prêtre
d'une pointe de toutes les vertus
le janus à replier l'ensemble et il
amène les éléments diacre sonné anti
chrome exister et interagir bon et là
encore pour un physicien théoricien le
réel ça s'écrit sur un tableau noir des
formules
par exemple si vous dites est ce que
vous pourriez m'expliquer ce que c'est
que la relativité restreinte
je dirais c'est formidable quand j'écris
des formules sur un bout de papier là ça
devient clair je n'ai pas que j'explique
mêmes on pourrait dire mais ce que vous
avez une image mentale dont on a plus
l'image mentale
justement les les scientifiques modernes
depuis le début du siècle
ben ils ont substitué les formalismes
aux images mentales c'est que ces sacs
d'étonnant l'exemple type c'est la
mécanique quantique ou à ce moment on
vous dira ne vous fait pas d une image
mentale vous avez le faut à tous les
cool ça ça va me donner ce prisonnier
d'une espèce de représentation des
choses qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité
donc on est obligé de passer par des
images par des aperçus par des points de
vue donc on va dire par exemple le
photon est à la fois une onde est une
particule alors qu'en fait c'est ma vie
c'est pas comme ça qu'on devrait dire ça
montre aussi les limites de notre
perception dans l'après ans
du réel complètement moment là on est le
scientifique est aussi désarmé que
l'homme de la rue vis-à-vis de ces
choses là seule chose vous savez ça fait
penser aux petits princes quoi dire que
l'officier était inquiet il habite
frites sur une planète de physique
théorique
et quand on lui pose des questions le
petit prince lui dire comment elle
réelle je te montrer il écrit d'état qui
joue au tableau c'est ça et donc vous
avez parlé du temps du rapport au temps
c'est vrai que dans une conception
métaphysique classique on va partir par
exemple de d'un acte créateur qu'on va
forcément un moment donné de voir
localisé dans le temps c'est à dire que
si la création et hors du temps ce qui
suit la création et dans le temps donc
la représentation d'un temps linéaire
d'un temps continue en tout cas de
risque des philosophes un j'entends qui
si on s'apercevait qu'il existe un temps
antiques rhône donc un temps qui va à
reculons pour nous ça remettrait
complètement en cause cette conception
métaphysique
moi jamais j'avais bien aimé discuter du
club ce qui s'est tellement intéressé
autant il ya des choses tout à fait
passionnante à dire là dessus alors le
truc c'est que finalement avec le
terrain de souriau les objets qui vivra
robuste ans simplement ils ont une
énergie une masse négative donc là ça va
alors à ce moment on se dit bon bain à
un moment donné l'univers bien c'est de
la matière de grimaces positive aux
étoiles et galaxies nous puis en même
temps cohabitent des choses qui soient
masse négatif alors il ya une chose
intéressante s'est interrogé comment
elle fait ce monde des masses négative
alors ce monde des masses négative
d'après les simulations janus lorsque
l'univers sort de la mort se forment des
conglomérats de l'as négative et qui
sont à ce moment-là ce verrou i do et
qui se comportent comme des proto
étoiles alors il s'est fait avec quoi et
bien c'est de l'anti matière mais c'est
de l'antihydrogène lentilles et les
hommes peut-être un petit peu d'anti dit
yom
puis les antilles électrons voilà c'est
tout des antilles mais ça ressemble
finalement au proto étoiles 2
univers sauf que le signe est différent
alors il est monsieur sait comment se
forment les étoiles bande comme cela il
se forme au départ c'est une protoétoile
essai de proto étoile et beaucoup plus
grand plus à l'heure actuelle je sais
pas je crois que ça doit être vrai de
l'orbiel de vénus quoi c'est un grand
nuage de gaz chaud comme ça qui est à
deux trois mille degrés qui rayonne et
il faut qu'il se débarrasse de sa
chaleur pour pouvoir se contracter et
que les réactions de fusion démarre donc
qu'on appelle faire le colleen klein ou
tendres en franchissement
alors donc une protoétoile quand elle se
forme à la veille du match om et cette
masse eh bien elle mais elle le volume
d'une sphère ses quatre tirs depuis hier
3 donc c'est comme le cube du rayon donc
plus la masse est grande plus volume est
important mais par contre elle rayonne
par sa surface qui varient comme le
carré c'est la pire 2 donc autrement dit
plus l'étoile est massive plus l énergie
a dégagé mais le radiateur ne sut pas
quand les étoiles massives en des temps
d'amorçage manquant tout le long alors
maintenant si on extrapole ça à ces
objets du monde négatif et bien ils ont
des temps de refroidissement qui dépasse
la jeune univers donc c'est des grosses
protoétoile qu'ils allument jamais qui
continue à rayonner dans le rouge et
l'infrarouge
alors ça une conséquence importante
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de fusion il n'y a
pas de morpho génèse particulière on
fabrique pas de carbone formule pas de
soufre donc ça reste comme ça en l'état
avec de l'antihydrogène d'anti l'hélium
il n'y a pas de briques de la vie n'y a
pas de planète et pas des toiles
soutenir badji donc dans cet univers
hors jeu raciste que vient de dire un
univers négatif parce que ces bruits
l'imam et à vivre la vie n'existe pas ou
n'existe pas alors âgé de deux amis des
deux jeunes lui ce qui est amusant c'est
justement au départ ces univers sont
amorphes donc que ce soit dans le monde
des masses musulmanes négative il n'ya
pas d'objets et à ce moment là
laisse une idée c'est que comment les
pensées peuvent ils existent et qu'elles
valent oui parce que pour qu'il pensait
pas qu'il est l'objet de penser on va et
là il y avait un seul coup derrière sur
quoi se concentrer et roxy s'il n'ya
rien pourquoi se concentrer est ce que
l'univers pense est-ce que les pensées
existe alors ça c'est amusant alors
après il ya le fameux paradoxe qui est
rigolo c'est se dire est ce qu'on va
essayer de remonter vers les origines
dans le big board wii alors à ce voile
avait entre remonte dans le passé et
vous savez que quand on remonte dans le
temps
l'univers devient de plus en plus chaud
et la chaleur c'est aussi les vitesses
d'agitation des particules est à ce
point mal comment ça argenté la vitesse
de la lumière
et quand elle tint vitesse de la lumière
une somme s'écoule plus vous savez
quelques particules les photons on lui
interdit nul dans leur temps propre
moi je dis bande dessinée qu'ils ont
leurs actes d ce qui collait au verso de
leur extrême des soirées très bien dit
oui voilà donc autrement dit fini ici à
dire je veut bien considérer le temps
mes amis quel horloge voilà la balance
est ce quelqu'un existe un ordre mais ça
s'est passé c'est parfait je fais je
vais vous soumettre des idées pistes des
idées puis vous allez réagir en tant qu'
en tant que physicien là dessus quand on
vieillit on a l'impression que les
années passent plus vite
bon alors on peut avoir une explication
logique c'est de dire bien quand on a 40
en un an c'est un 40e de notre vie alors
que quand on a 10 en un an c'est un
dixième donc en termes de proportion
effectivement il n'est pas délirant de
considérer que le temps passe plus vite
après on peut considérer que c'est
purement subjectif moi ça m'est arrivé
quelquefois d'avenir c'est amusant de
voir un chronomètre défilé avoir
l'impression que les secondes défilent
et très rapidement par rapport à leurs
enfants parce que quand j'étais enfant
j'arrivais à battre la mesure seconde
par seconde
et aujourd'hui quand je vois un chrono
mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ya eu un
drm donnons du temps tout ça pour dire
quoi parce que là on parle l'impression
subjective bien sûr tout ça pour dire
quoi que ça pose la question de savoir
si le temps s'écoule uniformément depuis
jour voit ce qu'il y à une vitesse du
temps qui peut varier la en tout cas à
l'échelle d'une vie humaine
moi je trouve que l'évocation est très
amusante parce que est ce que les
enfants vivent le temps est la même au
même rythme que nous moi je pense que
non
alors je vais vous donner un exemple
quand j'étais gosse je devais avoir 7 8
heures je me suis cassé une jambe dans
la station de lanières de la baule vite
est tombé d'un mur et il se trouve que
mon ami de benveniste avait une
appartement de vacances là bas donc je
suis allé un jour passer des vacances à
la gaule et je suis arrivé j'avais 45
ans et j'ai retrouvé la baule donc 40
ans plus tard et à soi tout avait
rétréci
il ya de la maison de mes paroles de
devis maison de poupée la distance qu'il
y avait entre le rouble est la mère
s'était rien du tout la place de la
république à côté c'était alors tout est
précis qui est incroyable attaque alors
le mur dont je m'étais nationale u18
avec sa corde il sait pas mais donc
autrement dit y'a une chose c'est que
comme à loches à un âge donné on est son
propre talent de longueur donc on alors
après imaginez qu'on lit qu'on fasse la
même chose avec le temps oui alors le
temps effectivement il faudrait imaginer
tout à coup un gosse qui canent occident
et qui rentre dans le coma à septembre
qui se réveille quarante ans à 8 ans et
là qu'est-ce qui se passerait oui à ce
moment là imaginer que à 40 ans ils
viennent visiter l'endroit où ils vivent
et comme il y avait 7 ans et à ce moment
là
et est-ce qu'il va tomber eelv a
l'impression que les choses vont très
vite
oui y'a une chose par exemple le fait
que les enfants vivent pas le temps la
même vitesse
c'est une chose qui les aiderait pour
l'apprentissage complètement
c'est à dire que pendant une seconde il
se passe énormément de choses
et regardez par exemple les autistes
vous rappeler le film rain man 2 sauf
quand il ya la pointe de piment dans le
peloton mais il y en a cent quarante
mais parce qu'il les a comptés oui ça va
bien pour eux il a vingt minutes pour
compter les
alors quand on ne sait de seconde ça
c'est très intéressant justement que
l'autisme cette forme d'autisme
c'est une terrible mode l'horloge
temporel et c'est pour ça qu'on n'arrive
pas à communiquer avec les autistes
parce que pour bouge trop lentement ou
trop vite mais oui c'est un truc il faut
imaginer tout d'un coup qu'on change de
chef de temps et jack boycott c'est
étonnant que toi et fais une marraine
bad est vraiment intéressant mais est-ce
qu'on est un moyen reste qu'on aurait un
moyen de vérifier que le temps s'écoule
de manière uniforme
est ce qu est un moyen un outil objectif
une horloge qui permettrait de le
mesurer
ou bien cette horloge serait elle même
soumise à cette évolution de la vitesse
d'écoulement du temps et du coup ce
serait non mesurables voyez ce que vous
traitez la mesure du temps c'est pas
difficile il n'y a pas 36 solutions
c'est un angle vous prenez votre montre
à une heure ces détours d'une aiguille
oui vous prenez la terre un jour c'est
le tour de la terre mois mais l'annoncé
autour de l'étoile soja voilà les hommes
parce que dira tout d'un coup je me
rappelle un joueur avec sur yon dans les
faits une conférence est jetée place des
anglais et je lisais on va faire une
expérience amusante
vous avez tous taper des mains en même
temps et quand on va faire ça ça va à
verser le temps et jeudi et vous ne
pouvez pas me prouver le contraire parce
que j'ai inversé le temps physique le
temps des particules le temple sikh vie
tout est inversé
et là il ya un an mais qui dit si vous
ça ne veut vous verrez al je préfère le
mettre
comme il est et avant c à c ur anglais
ils sont fortes et je pense que père
voilà mais veut dire que la pierre de
touche et les angles 1
alors le truc c'est effectivement quand
on cherche à ces explorer le temps dans
le passé à ce moment là on se dit je
vais prendre une horloge élémentaire ça
va être deux petites particules qui
tourne autour avec
autour dans son intégralité et puis le
hasard fait qu'elles ont pas fait de
mauvaise rencontre dire qu'elles sont
restées ça ça entré en collision avec
les autres bons alors à ce moment là ma
foi avec la physique classique si cette
chose-là est merveilleuse elle possible
eh bien mon horloge élémentaire fera un
nombre de tours fini jusqu'à l'instant
zéro mais d'un janus
il ya cette idée de constant de
variables qui explique l l'homogénéité
d'univers et à ce moment là quand on
pense modèle est bien plus on se
rapproche de la 100 0 puis il ya deux
tours et si le tour c'est le temps ça
veut dire que le l'instant origines mais
c'est pareil de nous comme atteinte
physique
notre favorite et de s'échapper mais
c'est assez drôle comme ça bien leur en
plus supposant avec de la chance vous
arrivait justement
oui vous rappeler le paradoxe d'achille
et de la tortue h ils étaient à dix
mètres de la tortue alors achille fait à
m et la tortue fait dix centimètres
alors à symphony cm et finalement ils
rattrapent jamais les tortues et là bas
j'ai fait ça dans de mes vidéos h ils
essayent de rattraper tortueux mais plus
il a rappelé au plus vite
il finit par mourir parce que le une
fois toi philippe au lycée l'horloge qui
sonne qui s'emballe comme ça donc il ya
six mois et laurent plus si d'aventuré
on a la chance d'arriver justement ce
graal du temporel de ce côté on fasse un
point négatif négatif donc à ce moment
là est ce que le sens est ce qu avance a
un sens et en fait c'est assez rigolo
parce que il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas
de temps absolu et des points de vue
tout honneur on disait que les objets
n'existe pas il est l'heracles les
relations entre le voilà ouais bah là
aussi mais le sens où c'est arbitraire
alors ça ça demanderait réfection de
philosophie en interaction avec les
scientifiques savaient peut-être les
scientifiques disent pas d'aimer tease
et on dit tous de bêtises surnommé
manqué bêtise en sort pour voir s'ils en
faisaient exploser
exxon cantine quand il mettait en
opposition le temps physique et le temps
psychologique pour montrer qu'il y avait
deux conceptions de temps d'arrêter en
pot même en trouver d'autres
j'imagine temps historique par exemple
et ce sera intéressant qu'il y ait un
dialogue entre philosophes et
scientifiques sur scène ils sont là
parce que finalement le temps est aussi
un paramètre utilisé en sens de dire
c'est une veste une valve qu'on utilise
et à partir de là on est obligé de
obligés d'entendre ce que les physiciens
haut à nous en dire d'autant que quand
vous disiez au moment du big bang le
temps de s'écouler pas la même façon
ainsi pour hommes le big bang pour
schématiser de ce petit ils ont dit
lundi gbadji cela jusque là on est dans
la partie philosophe chiens et la partie
un peu plus libre de l'entretien parlons
du parlant du big bang
qu'est ce que vous auriez indien sur ce
modèle alors j'explique juste peut-être
l'intérêt de la question au niveau
philosophique c'est que le big bang et
souvent à tort d'ailleurs considéré
comme étant l'instant zéro ou en tout
cas le le début le commencement
l'univers ce qui est évident pose la
question oui mais s'il ya un
commencement qu'est ce qu'il y avait
avant ce commencement puisque le big
bang n'est pas sûr juste surgi du néant
ou alors si mais dans ce cas là il va
falloir qu'on nous explique donc d'après
vous quel est le problème avec 700 g à
la fin d'un chiot de quoi dispose-t-on
produits observationnelles ça c'est très
important
la première chose qu'on a pu observer
c'est justement la cendre du big bang ce
sont ces photos et vous rappeler que
quand penzy ac et wilson ont mis à une
grande antenne pour disons que les
américains avaient décidé de mettre un
satellite qui s'appelait et coke était
un grand ballon argenté la smala on
allait envoyer des des ondes radio
qu'elle laisse réfléchir de ce ballon et
il se trouve que ces ondes
c'était les mêmes que celles qu'on
allait utiliser
avec celle et là lorsqu'ils ont mis à
l'antenne
il amène réceptionne le ballon n'était
pas lancée il n'y avait rien alors
rappelez vous qu ils ont pensé que
c'était peut-être les pigeons qui était
d'un dock et ils ont éloigné les pions
près les gens manger toute la folk leur
insu mais après ce qu'ils ont aperçu
c'est que il y avait le même rayonnement
quelle que soit la direction d'un quel
homme était ce corps n'est donc c'était
un rayonnement radio qu'ils viennent
tout les sens et à ce moment là il ya un
cosmologistes qu'il a été formidable
vous venez de vérifier la théorie de
l'explosif
vous avez la cendre c'est extraordinaire
la voilà la plus concrète c'est ce qu'on
a mais on n'a rien d'autre parce que
vous savez quand on essaye d'observer
dans le passé mais il ya un moment où on
se heurte à ce murano plan que ça soit
bien avant l inconscience ans milan
justement
oui par exemple quand on veut faire des
observations et bien ce qu'il ya de
formidable c'est qu'on arrive à voir des
objets qui sont à 7 8 milliards
d'années-lumière ça signifie que les
photons que je vais capturés sur la
pellicule
il a réussi à faire 7 milliards d'années
lumière sans rencontrer personne
donc ça veut dire que lui n'y était
extrêmement transparent quoi ah ouais ok
et qu'est ce que c'est les transports
c'est un objet ou les photos plus grosse
batterie sans l'avoir problème bon
maintenant il ya les objets opaque
c'est pas dur vous mettez à l'écran boom
sa posture bien vous avez là comment
dire l'intermédiaire
c'est la glace de salle de bain qui est
translucide
vous renvoyez le corps peu de femmes qui
tout flou par derrière voilà j'ai fait
ça et bien lorsqu'on cherche à voir dans
le passé on arrive à ce mur où justement
l'univers la tragique les photos tout
devient fou et on vous avait déjà vu
cette image de l'univers primitif et on
ne peut pas voir au delà parce que ce
qu'on voit ça n'est rien d'autre que des
interprétations de cet objet quoi est
une sorte de frontières temporelles
alors après bon bah y'a un théoricien
kidioui aucune problème je vais remonter
dans le passé il ya un type qui
s'appelait stephen belber kyi prix nobel
qui a fait un bouquin qui a marqué son
temps je trouvais ça formidable qu'il
appelait the fuck u minutes les trois
premières minutes et ce livre là c'était
une
ceylan de vulgarisation justement sur ce
problème de la jeunesse cosmique mais il
disait moi je préfère démarrer au 1er
centièmes de seconde
parce que là je vois ce qui se passe
mais avant je trouve que j'ai très foot
et c'est vrai quand on est aux premiers
antienne secondes
et bien voilà on a le monde avec les
protons les antiprotons l'une trou mais
quand on remonte avant mais ben on va
avoir le ventre des quark alors la
question c'est que tout ce qu'on
imaginait pas tout ce qu'on a élucubrer
après avec les rues de symétrie des
trucs des machins etc
et puis après on arrive au mur de planck
et qu'est-ce qui avant le mur de planck
tout ça donne bien diverses et la
spéculation
regardez par exemple cette théorie de
l'inflation l'inflation ne fait partie
du money cosmologique
quand vous gagnez chebah vous avez vu
vous avez un point aux petits d'un coup
ça rentre comme ça mais pourquoi cette
expansion aussi rapide là parce que
lorsqu'on a observé le cosmos dans son
hôtel plus primitifs on l'a trouvée
homogène à un cent millième près alors
hommage n la sortie du mien bresse à
dire que la densité la température c'est
la même partout mais alors si c'est
comme ça c'est que les particules ont pu
interagir et comment font-elles pour
interagir alors que dans la théorie du
big bang elle s'éloigne plus vite que la
vitesse de la lumière
voyez merci de donner un exemple
imaginez vous habitez un pays et ce pays
est en train de se dilater et à ce
moment là vous avez des villages comme
ça et ils sont dix stands on voit le
village on atteint et on décide
oui les cavaliers vers les autres
villages pour porter un message est
malheureusement le cheval va moins vite
que la dilatation
c'est à dire que le la distance entre
les villageois demande tellement vite
que qu'un lion se rapproche pour ces
mêmes
et là il ya un moment que celle
s'inverse enfin il finit par arriver
et là à ce moment là il n'ya pas son
message donc voilà on va pouvoir changer
pourquoi parler la même langue là ce
cosmos primitif c'est comme si toutes
les particules de la lumière parler le
même langage alors quelle honte à
échanger un bon donc ça il fallait
trouver une explication alors c'est le
russe timide et qui a proposé sa en 1988
il a dit l'univers a subi
une inflation de 10 puissance 30 37 à 10
puissance moins 33 secondes et tout
m'était 25,0 en fait c'est n'importe
quoi
alors appelez on pourrait dire mais
qu'est ce qui provoque cette inflation
hausse et des particules qui s'appelle
un flat on their flattot qu'est ce que
c'est r moi j'ai rencontré de
l'astrophysicienne ya quelques semaines
qui me disait il ya autant de flat tant
que théoricien à surmonter avec bordeaux
3e c'est parce que c'est donc vous voyez
il y avait lors du vide qui permet tait
ouvert que pour toi les baromètres et la
flatte ou qui permet alors après qu'est
ce que c'est là flattons basse est un
composant essentiel qui va se
transformer en un an après en matière
alors avant même d'arriver comme planque
franchement c'est un c'est la fiction
quoi pour est un peu modeste comme à
kiev est ce qu'on peut dire je ne
comprends pas ça avait tout simplement
je crois moi je crois qu'il faut un
appel à la modestie qu il faut et il
faut être ambitieux il faut quand même
connaître ses limites
oui je vous rejoins dans le sens où
c'est vrai que la tentation de spéculer
sur un avant ou sur un ailleurs est
grande
parfois en dépit des faibles éléments
dont on dispose
mais l'argent justement continuons parce
que on parlait du big bang
on parlait de la matière ça ne conduit
aussi à la question de la vie la vie de
ses origines de sa nature
alors moi j'ai quand même en question à
vous poser simplement parce que sinon je
me fais engueuler peut-on concevoir une
vie autrement que selon les modalités
physique qu'on lui connaît sur terre
c'est à dire que quand on parle de vie
dans l'univers
est ce qu'on parle de quelque chose qui
serait aux structures et de la même
manière que les la vie sur terre
ou est ce qu'on peut imaginer d'autres
formes de vie va écouter est d'abord une
chose qui est pas même qui datent de la
sorte c'est de voir que la nature sur le
plan physique n'a pas autant
d'imagination que cox a regardé par
exemple au départ il ya l'hydrogène
après ça fait du carbone ça fait du souk
juste comme ça qu'ils avaient la table
f avec cessantes atom et bien ce sont
les mêmes sans atome dans tout l'univers
et pourquoi mais parce que ce qui se
forment c'est ce qui est probable ce qui
est stable vous avez fait une expérience
amusante dans le temps wendel est assez
impressionnant on prend une baguette en
bois de section cylindrique la taille de
mon petit doigt
puis on découvre des petits cylindres
comme ça alors paul nous avons appelé il
ya une espèce de crochets qu'on accroche
sur les rideaux d'à côté c'est un anneau
de mézin crochet donc vous mettez un
anneau d'à côté accroché de l'autre
si vous en mettez une trentaine dans un
sac et vous secouer et quand vous
renversez y en a un certain nombre
d'attachés ayala qu'ils soient déçus par
deux y en a quelques-uns par trois c'est
assez rigolo c'est que vous ne pouvez
pas faire ses expériences sans qui
s'attachent d'être la probabilité qu'ils
seraient tous des tâches est possible
maintenant la priorité soit tout ce
qu'il fallait un collier ce n'est pas
besoin non plus donc vous avez un
problème de probabilités et même si vous
faites l'expérience cent fois vous allez
avoir une certaine proportion de temps
de machin l'attaché de foix iii examiner
un box donc vous voyez là on a la
morphogénèse la nucléosynthèse
primordiale vous l'avez sous les yeux
alors c'est vrai que quand vous prenez
des petites sphères aimante et moi
j'avais un jeu comme ça dans le temps
mais quand vous en prenez qu'elle vous
fait commun un empilement de boulet que
vous avez trois boulets un autre ça
c'est un atome d'hélium et c'est très
géométrique
il est très stable donc se forment donc
c'est stable maintenant un truc avec
celle boulet ou là ça va pas et en fait
on retrouve par exemple c'est sur lui
qui me disait que quand on prend le
carbone et 3 x 4
c'est un peu comme s'il y avait trois
hélium et c'est vrai que si on avait un
système où on puisse fabriquer des
noyaux avec des boules et bien il ya des
nombre magique qui fait qu'on arrivera
sur des choses affreuses ferrique la
cour ajoute nucléo savap à quoi bon donc
voyez c'était il ya cette notion
d'harmonie de résonance de symétrie de
stabilité donc avec ça ça nous sécrète
toutes ces atomes qui ont des propriétés
vachement spécifique le carbone et et
ravalant et
le carbone il a il apparaît dans tout
l'univers et en même proportion qu'en
mais assez extraordinaire alors à ce
moment là regardez par exemple des gens
qui disaient encore il ya 30 ou 40 ans
qui vous dit que nous ne sommes pas la
seule place dans l'univers
vous l'avez vu maintenant à quel chiffre
on arrive veut dire l'apparition de ces
planètes et quelque chose d'absolument
hallucinant ensuite à aux fabuleux sur
les formes de vie qui peuvent exister
mais pourquoi est ce que la nature
aurait plus d'imagination là dedans
regardez par vous avez sur terre des
biotopes différents prenez par un peu
l'australie vous avez des oiseaux de
trêve vous avez des animaux des
magiciens des placentaires 1 comme les
kangourous el khabar supplie alléger le
marsupial c'est les flots mais non ne
font pas cette place
ce placenta laquelle nous fûmes el mami
et malienne on voit là et mais pourtant
le rat marsupial des très proches du ram
amis même y faire ma valise des trucs
comme ça
l'outil là si c'était presque un loup
normal donc vous avez des variations
relativement important mais avec des
convergences
alors ça ça pose un problème est ce
qu'il y a des est ce que on est homme
appelle des créoles des skis à des soins
préférentiels vous savez quand vous avez
c'est pas une rivière qui coule
vous avez des bruns des rivières qui se
forme il peut y avoir effectivement du
diverticule et puis ça finit par
converger est ce que il ya une
convergence et quelles sont les règles
de cette convergence l'aigle convergence
et la performance
si on a deux yeux c'est que c'est
vachement commode pour faire l'idiot
serreau scopique c'est pas la peine d'en
avoir trois par exemple donc voilà et
puis la station debout les mains c'est
commode
donc vous avez des gens qui vous parle
jamais
venir j'ai vu débarquer des gens il y
avait deux bras deux jambes et deux yeux
on dit mais vous rendez compte
regardez la guerre des mondes de wells
avec ses c'est poupe tentaculaire est-ce
que les autres planètes sont habités par
des vénus intelligente
la question est posée moi je serais
tenté de penser qu' il ya déjà sur têt
les différences morphologiques l'énorme
regardez par exemple entre le plus grand
géant qui faisait trois mètres et le
plus petit nain qui est de 50 cm voir
décoller la différence emplois qu'il ya
c'est énorme énorme alors déjà ça donne
des variables après il ya des tas de
choses très curieuse peut-être que la
planète a connu des taux d'oxygène
différends dans le passé ce qui
expliquerait tout d'un coup des grands
animaux ou des petits parce que
justement suivant la rue sans oxygène
bonjour on vit pas de la même façon
donc tout ça rien qu'en regardant ce qui
se passe sur notre planète
nous avons une idée des variations de ce
qui peut se passer par nous vous avons
un truc c'est de temps en temps et des
mutations et les souches humaines
donnent naissance à des comment
s'appellent ces gens qui n'ont pas de
pigment déjà des albinos dominos les
animaux sont très sensibles à la lumière
à tel point qu'il veut apporter d'une
laque noire bon il arrive à avoir une
vieille renault molle mais ils sont
sensibles au soleil alors la question
qui se pose c'est est-ce que ce serait
pas tout d'un coup petite tentative de
du génome humain vous fabriquez des
êtres nyctalope vivent la nuit
voilà l'état il ya une chose que
j'aurais bien aimé faire retrouver à
tiques qui puisse faire exister son
ennemi de [ __ ] pour tester leur
sensibilité olfactive
personne n'a jamais fait un truc pareil
même auditive est ce qu'ils sont est-ce
qui est ce qu'ils entendent mieux parce
que quand vous prenez des créatures
nocturnes la vision c'est moi j'apporte
ans et l'infrarouge qui compte fait ils
ont une sorte d'art déjà la peau blanche
est beaucoup plus sensible que c'est
comme ça qu'ils valent jc la lumière est
ensuite est ce qu est ce qu il y aura
une faction plus importante donc
imaginez une planète où les hommes
soient nyctalope unis vivaldi mais il ya
plein de mammifères qui vivent la nuit
vous allez au kenya 90% des espèces
vivent à lui le jour il propose selon
des terriers oui c'est ainsi que vous
avez des tas de rei animaux dans lequel
le rythme aujourd'hui est inversé alors
j'ai envie de prolonger un peu ce que
vous dites bond de plusieurs manières
c'est à dire là il ya un bon nombre de
personne je pense qu'ils vont vous vous
reprocher de faire sur l'appel du
finalisme c'est à dire d'avoir une
attention dans la nature alors moi si
vous permettez je veux je vais m'occuper
de cette objection en répondant que on
peut très bien remplacer le finalisme
tout simplement par l'idée d'adaptation
du vivant à son milieu qu'est-ce qui
survit c'est ce qui est adapté
donc à partir de là on n'est pas obligé
de voir une intention d'être personnifié
qui serait la nature mais simplement de
voir un moment donné des simplement des
des phénomènes d'adaptation voilà qui
vont tendre vers une convergence
évolutive et comme pour les molécules
toutes les molécules n'existe pas tous
les atomes non plus qui vous dit qu'il
ya pas d planète il n'existe pas de
carbone dont je m'excuse c'est pas
possible
oui déjà alia il ya du gaz carbonique il
ya forcément parce qu'il ya forcément de
la paix partout et et si on se prolonge
un petit peu en groupe on peut aussi
observer une forme d' équilibre dans la
dans la répartition c'est-à-dire que je
prendrai une allégorie c'est celle
allégorique tout le monde connaît de
prométhée et qu'il était donc on
rappelle epiméthée été chargé de faire
la distribution des caractéristiques
chez les animaux voilà il devait
répartir les attributs donc il a donné à
tête d'animaux la vitesse à d'autres la
force etc
et puis un moment donné il arrive alors
mais il s'est rendu compte qu'il avait
oublié l'homme cauchemar c'est son frère
prométhée qui arrivent pour réparer les
conneries et qui dit bon ben je vais
essayer de retrouver quelque chose aux
hommes pour
ils puissent quand même un peu tenir et
s'adapter et c'est là où il décide
d'aller voler le feu aux dieux de le
transmettre aux hommes et voilà les
hommes se retrouve finalement avec la
connaissance l'intelligence qui leur
permet de sueur de survivre et de sa
date d face aux animaux et du coup bah
ça va bien évidemment la question de la
conscience dirons-nous en tout cas de
l'intelligence et plus exactement de la
relation entre le corps et l'esprit
voilà donc là ça va nous amener
peut-être assez loin mais bon alors je
dis bien voilà je prends la
responsabilité
ce sera dit dans cette vidéo donc j'en
veux un petit est ce que votre modèle
janus prévoit une conception du rapport
entre le corps et l'esprit le corps et
la conscience l'intelligence appelons ça
comme on veut ou bien indépendamment de
votre modèle peut-être avez-vous le dr
c'est plutôt indépendamment parce que ce
modèle faut quand même pas lui faire
dire tout ce qu'il savait la plus belle
fille du momment de bain un film plus
que ce qu'elle a là vous prenez deux
équations de ça on va pas leur faire
sortir des miracles cancale
on appelle ça janus je crois que c'est
un peu exagéré mais eux les prologues
simuler ses je pense à mon maître
souriau mathématicien j'ai passé des
heures fantastique avec lui il habite
aix-en-provence
donc on était voisins et j'ai pu
bénéficier discussions pendant des
années avec légalement avec grothendieck
qui était également un voisin alors le
truc c'est que l'idée force de so you
s'étaient dites moi dans quel espace
je dois considérer les choses considérez
vous remarquez c'est m l'étoile ensemble
ces médecins oui considéré je n'avais
pas dit quand je me considère c'est que
je mais voilà alors donc de quel espace
s'agite yves et si j'ai les propriétés
mathématiques de cet espace qui se
traduit par le mot groupe
moi je peux savoir quels sont les
habitants de cet espace bon alors qu'est
ce que je vais prendre et ça sautille
imparable soulignant avec un groupe qui
celui des translations vie des rotations
des symétries alors sur lui on fait
tourner sa petite machine mathématiques
il ya d'ailleurs des droites il doit y
avoir des plans à lui demander ses accus
demeurent des sphères tous les objets
géométriques apparaissent
mathématiquement non place père n'est
plus un levier des points il ya distance
d'un point central
donc c'est quelque chose qui est un
variant quand on le fait tourner à
l'intérieur de lui-même faisait abstrait
bon alors c'est très joli
alors après on se dit mais on va essayer
autre chose prenons les spas de l'
activité restreinte avant alors c'est
quoi ça s'appelle l'espace 2000 cops qui
est le groupe mathématiques qui virent
ça c'est le groupe de poincaré
alors à ce moment là quels sont les
habitants mais soin de minkowski ce sont
des mouvements et des mouvements
particuliers sac les particules sont
définis par exemple sur ie disait
dis-moi qui comment tu te me je te
dirais quoi tuer waouh c'est julie alors
ça ça se déplace comme ça brasse la
photo ça c'est pas comme ça c'est de la
matière alors là où c'est extraordinaire
c'est que ces lacs justement quand on se
met à faire des maths ça produit plus
que ce qu'on avait cru pendant qu'ils
font un espace
claudia g groupe de clean et puis une
matrice mathématiquement et ça produit
un truc qui est l'asymétrie miroir
autrement dit j'ai un tire-bouchon
paraît donc voilà tire-bouchon toujours
à sortir bouchons de 1 et cellules en
plus c'est un tire-bouchon farzin trappe
c'est à dire que on ouvre la bouteille à
tout vent au sens donc tout d'un coup
que j'ai hâte yang ho cho et mon groupe
de great deal doit exister le tout est
au chaud alors que c'est comme les
particules en physique voilà une
particule est ce qu'il existe un type
gentil cochon l'antiparticule oui ça
existe mais il ya il est dans le monde
des farces et attrapes le mac mini est
là justement le groupe de poids car il
dit doit exister que c'est beau ça c'est
formidable ça a créé le réel et à ce
moment là le modèle apparaît et sa
rencontre des phénomènes d'interactions
alors ensuite bas on a donc des
particules d'énergie possible d'énergie
négative etc et on peut pousser ça plus
loin en disant et si nous habitions dans
l'espace de l'ermite à puisque c'est un
espace de leur vie c'est un espace de
2006 complexifier alors je sais pas si
vous spectateurs ça ce que c'est que les
complexes avec racines de -1
mais c'est une façon déplier ce truc là
et à ce moment-là bomba quel est le
groupe qui pilote ça a bossé poincaré
complexe un bon alors on prend la
machine en serions au tourne et on voit
apparaître des masses réel et des masses
imaginaire et des masques en place et ça
ça ressemble à un jeu de lego pour la
physique la métaphysique
alors bon j'ai fait un bouquin là dessus
les gens le dire on ne sait pas comment
les gens vont réagir mais oui c'est
bizarre parce que tout d'un coup c'était
litres et qui disait la métaphysique est
un grand lac pour le traverser une
véronique barthe qui voile et là tout
d'un coup c'est le cas nos automobiles
avec le moteur hors-bord monte alors
franchement on va vous dire écoutez
hors top physicien j'ai fait ça vous
qu'ils désavouent l'état qu'on
réfléchisse à ces jeux alors vous avez à
garder un petit peu comment ça se
présentait c'est assez nous aurons alors
ce qui est particulièrement amusant
justement quand on déploie s'adaptant
c'est qu'au départ
l'univers à quatre types de base + m
moiselle et puis plusieurs moisi m
elles sont toutes à différencier cirque
en fait on ne sait pas quelles sont les
masses qui vont être positifs qui vont
être négative et celles qui sont réels
ou imaginaires ça c'est amusant les
rôles sont redistribués
mais à un moment effectivement il ya une
partie qui va constituer la réalité et
l'autre cette méta réalité donc du côté
de la réalité ça commence par être
amorphe ya juste des particules comme ça
qu'ils forment un ensemble homogène
craint médicaux mais tes maîtres
métaphysique c'est pareil les pensées
n'existe pas encore c'est normal je n'ai
pas de pipi comment voulez vous qu'ils
fassent ça existe c'est assez rigoureux
comme taïwan une philosophie que ce sera
amusant alors je me permets de vous
demander des clarifications on doit donc
faire une précision voilà pour nos
auditeurs
donc on parle ici en fait des
mathématiques complexes
alors on va juste se rappeler la
distinction donc il ya les mathématiques
avec les nombres qu'on appelle est réel
donc les réelles
ça va des nombres entiers naturels
jusqu'au son nombre irrationnel
voilà et ensuite on entre dans une
catégorie qui sont les nombres et
imaginaire et donc vous avez cité
racines de moins on rappelle à nos
auditeurs qui ne savait qui est inventé
un endroit racines des voisins c'est car
ben ouais
car dan aux cessions d'actifs et ça et
qu'est ce qu'il avait en tête quand il
ya je crois ce qu'il voulait résoudre
une équation du troisième degré on ya
trouvé commode d'inventer ce truc là et
c'est assez étonnant parce que il a
inventé à l'objet colossal et ils
savaient pas à quoi cela pourrait servir
car dans nos affiches chose qui a fallu
l'ouvreur de gros ennuis et acquisitions
un moment il a calculé le thème astral
du christ à aa affalé aux essais faut la
regarder les flammes est hélas là
vraiment il était imbu de plurilinguisme
si lui et son ascendant l'europe l'heure
a sonné lundi obligé de payer des ducats
pour parler en prison les tortures et
saufs rien mais c'est vrai si on a la
date de naissance du christ on connaisse
son signal intéressant c'est assez
marrant par exemple frapper alors je
prenais le train avec un jeune
séminariste dans un train de nuit comme
ça on a discuté
effectivement j'aurais pu lui demander
est ce que quelqu'un s'est posé la
question de savoir qualité signe
astrologique du christ mais même je lui
demandai à bâbord à votre avis est-ce
qu'ils étaient génétiquement compatible
et qu'elle soit si bête et il m'a dit
alors ça on n'a jamais quitté sa ans et
demi alors justement pour reprendre là
dessus pourquoi c'est intéressant parce
que nous a priori le monde physique on
va l'appréhender avec avec les nombreux
réel en tout cas avec les mathématiques
ou qu'on apprend vous avez fait physique
ça une étymologie grecque fusil sa
nature oui c'est la manifestation ah oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai physique 6 qui se
donnait à voir
on est très beau autres c'est très beau
et est d'ailleurs justement l'imaginaire
pour le coup ne se laisse pas voir de
manière directe donc site extraordinaire
c'est qu'on ait appelé sera sydney - ses
hameaux imagine oui voilà pour rappel
pour nous pour nos auditeurs qui
auraient oublié leurs cours de collège
par définition un nombreux car elle peut
pas être négatif donc la racine car
l'aide d'un homme négatifs comme moins
jeunes n'est pas possible mais dans les
mathématiques ça s'utilise et non de
l'imaginaire supprimer complètement fou
alors justement est ce que en rapport
avec la question que je vous ai posé
dans mon précédent de l'entretien est ce
qu'il y aurait une application physique
ou métaphysique du coup pour le coup 2
c'est mathématique complexe dénombre
imaginaire est ce que ça peut être mis
en relation des quelque chose selon vous
si vous les savez en physique est ce
qu'on appelle la top model à modène
jouer alors
ça veut dire que théoricien a tout à
coup une idée et si ceci si seul at on
va voir ce que ça donnerait bon moi j'ai
joué avec ça dans mon bouquin est ce
mois là ça me ça nous dit par exemple
nous avons eu dames et elle survit après
notre mort ça c'est bon ce physique moi
alors je devrais être arrêté pour
exercice illégal de la physique et de la
vérité mais c'est un porte une réponse
là où la science d'un produit aucune
parce que vous savez moi j'ai 83 ans
dont supposons que j'ai 10 ans
d'espérance de vie ça passe très vite
83 on se dit que la coutume je vais
mourir un jour
moi j'ai un ami qui a aussi son ensemble
billet de sortie
ces jours-ci quoi et c'est tout le temps
comme ça
donc est-ce que c'est licite de
réfléchir sur sa famille parce que
regarder un peu les problèmes de femme
dit qu'elle en parle de quoi on parle du
confort est ce que on peut faire en
sorte que je ne souffre pas bon d'accord
ensuite est ce que il ya l'euthanasie
ici c'est pas idiot non plus parce que
pourquoi souffrir comme un imbécile dans
des trucs épouvantable
quand on sait que c'est foutu vous avez
pas une façon de d'aller vers la mort
qui est la maladie d'alzheimer
ça c'est effrayant parce que il ya une
dégradation des individus quittent
absolument épouvantable et l'euthanasie
est autorisée en belgique par exemple
pour les gens qui ont ce genre de choses
ils peuvent décider qu'ils veulent
arrêter et il ya qu un assez célèbre en
belgique d'un type qui est écrivain
homme de lettres très connu tout d'un
coup on lui avait diagnostiqué sa bombe
quand il a commencé à sentir les
prémices de ce truc là j'ai pas envie
dit ça j'ai pas envie de faire un livre
aux autres donc il a dit au revoir à
tout le monde
puis il a bu un petit coup et voilà il
n'y a pas de quoi en faire un plat
est ce que c'est une qu'est ce que ça
apporte de voir des gens se transformer
en legging s'effrayant quoi donc
déjà il ya ce chemin vert à mort comment
le vivent dans la salle en question
métaphysique pour le coup par excellence
le poser heidegger l'homme est un être
la mort il est un outil qui est
conscient d'aller vers la mort donc
automatiquement sa soul avant lui
l'angoissé métaphysique qui va amener
ensuite allée des conceptions
métaphysique telles que celles que vous
vous présentez là où telle que celle que
nous devons présenter d'autres qui nous
offre tout au long de l'histoire et on
peut ne pas adhérer à ses conceptions il
est relégué au rang de croyance ou une
opinion un peu farfelue mais le fait est
qu'à un moment donné la question se pose
oui mais la science s'arrête à l'instant
place en finale que c'est tout et comme
vous avez des gens comme charbonnier
avec l'histoire de l'inde ait eu ces
gens là où il frôle la suspension par le
conseil des médecins
moi je suis pas il ya peut-être un
conseil des cosmologistes mais qui le
connaissent il existe avant la livraison
jours sont comptés mais il ya conseil
d'état par exemple
oui ma mère est morte d'un cancer il ya
un important d'un cancer au foie et donc
elle est morte dans une clinique à saint
tropez et ma foi comme j'habitais que je
venais d'avoir le plus souvent possible
et elle est décédée quand j'étais pas là
donc quand je suis arrivé les firmes
comme appui après la bcd et en regardant
dans cette tenue j'ai trouvé des
feuillets que j'ai lu et elle pas que
j'ai rien compris
elle m'a décrit une n2 complète
quand j'ai vu six avec la tunnel gens
qui faisait coucou tétouan et elle
n'avait jamais rien lu de là dessus et
moi non plus c'est moi j'ai cru que
c'était du délire
c'est ainsi que y donc voilà un truc est
standard moi je me rappelle van der
celle qui a été un des premiers à écrire
un bouquin là dessus que ça peut être
sur ce douar vous rappelez pas un
français et van der c'est l'été un
journaliste et actuel et il s'était
intéressé à des gens comme elisabeth
hubert ross qui s'est intéressé
justement ou mourants quoi
l'accompagnement des mourants et quand
ils interrogeaient les scientifiques les
gens disaient oui mais cette histoire de
de restriction du chancellier
au manque d'irrigation de la rétine et
puis je veux dire tous ces phénomènes
étaient des trucs hallucinatoire liés à
ceux ci est ce qu'on avait montré qu'ils
avaient des sécrétions non non il
fallait absolument s'excuser devant des
recettes
il fallait absolument invalidé et toutes
ces idées quoi parce que c'est moi vous
si on s'approchait de quelque chose qui
n'était pas autorisée quand vous les
fondre mais voilà alors effectivement
pour un scientifique
c'est du délire bon niçois comme ça il y
en a plein couac est disons que vous
vous rappelez il y avait un livre
atik avait écrit ce livre sur
l'intellect notre une exploration du
monde des morts bon bah il ya des
cultures asiatique et indienne pour qui
cette réflexion est tout à fait licite
jelloun on chez nous il ya un mur on
s'arrête là on veut bien donner toutes
les drogues qu'il faudra accompagner les
gens dangereux dernier moment mais après
après ça s'arrête
c'est complètement fou que le whisky est
complètement contre-productif d'ailleurs
parce que ça pousse justement les gens à
se retrancher dans justement ce qu'on
peut appeler des croyances qui ne sont
pas qu'ils ne sont pas considérés qui
sont pas prises au sérieux du tout et du
coup ça ça incite pas du tout à un mieux
comprendre céder ce genre de phénomène
donc c'est très dommage tout le monde y
perd malgré l'impressionnant dans cette
espèce de voile à de rejet alors
justement pour revenir à la question de
la relation entre le corps et l'âme
moi j'aimerais avoir peut-être pour
terminer cette cet entretien elle votre
votre conception
je vais d'abord rappelé la pression de
platon qui me parlent intéressantes
comme le point de départ d'une réflexion
platon disait voilà il y a il ya au delà
du monde sensible il y à un monde
intelligible ce sont les idées qui sont
fixés éternelle et il y as en dessous le
monde sensible qui est une sorte de
projection en mouvement de ce monde
intelligible et il expliqué pas compte
que l'homme l'homme possédait une âme
une âme tripartite dont la partie la
plus basse était en connexion avec
l'élément terre
l'élément physique matérielle et la
partie supérieure c'était la partie
c'était l'esprit ont fait qu'à
participiez rituel qui étaient connectés
à ce monde des idées et pour m
intéresser un petit peu à la philosophie
à l'ésotérisme et à la science
j'ai trouvé intéressant de me demander
mais est ce que finalement le le but de
la vie le but qu'on se donne un le but
individuel de notre vie n'est pas de ct
vers ce monde des idées de se
débarrasser de tout ce qui pollue notre
âme soient les religions on appelle les
péchés par exemple mais qu'on peut
retrouver aussi sous d'autres termes
pour s'élever vers ce monde des idées
qui représentait comme étant le paradis
tandis qu'au contraire le fel de bain
d'être uniquement dans la matérialité
dans la pesanteur dans la gravité bas ce
serait ce qu'on représente comme étant
l' enfer fait les indiens il modélise a
aussi à leur façon avec des corps vous
avez une corps astral de corée d'eric
corps mental pour cette structure d'état
ville c'est comme les poupées russes
mais voilà c'est ça que vous avez une
poupée qui gère les sentiments les
désirs voilà il fit après même le
vocabulaire qu'on utilise quand on dit
par exemple je sais au plus bas
al'inverse on dit que on est dans la
légèreté
on voit là des choses comme ça on voit
bien qu'il ya un champ lexical qui est
structurelle et plus début comme étant
ce qui nous ramène vers le bas c'est
cette idée de poids de pesanteur qu'on
associé à l'enfer dans les religions
al'inverse vendent le ciel c'est
évidemment le paradis c'est dieu etc
mais finalement est-ce que vous vous
c'est vraiment votre avis personnel que
je vous demande est ce qu'il ya une
réalité de l'âme ou est ce que ce n'est
qu'un concept est quelque chose de
symbolique
je crois que ça fait réel mais ce que je
veux dire six blessés que dans
l'attitude qu'on peut avoir vis-à-vis de
la vie est ce qu'on se replie sur sa
personnalité
ou est-ce qu'on se considère comme
interaction une interaction avec son
environnement pour moi l'interaction de
camions allemands c'est très important
bah quand je vois tout ce qui ce qui se
déroule sur air france en ce moment
c'est sans abri ces choses là etc
je trouve que nous avons un manque
d'empathie c'est grave et en fait pour
moi
le devenir des vivants c'est vraiment
d'améliorer la condition générale la
corruption globale
nous sommes là pour pour communiquer
pour comment dire pour collaborer pour
un plan et ce plan justement c'est la
communication et cette communication
nous sommes arrivés à l'époque où cette
communication va être extra terrestre
parce que si justement le modèle janus
permet les voyages interstellaires
c'est qu'on va les faire donc simplement
et la voyez comment dire il ya un tuyau
c'est que ça n'est pas un oiseau qui a
des ailes gigantesque qui arriverait à
nous transporter valais les prochaines
étoiles c'est forcément la technologie
donc la technologie nécessaire et la
technologie c'est un prolongement
évolutif nous avons des pouvoirs
difficiel des crises terrain artificiel
des couteaux nous faisons une digestion
artificiel dans les cuisines pour
transformer la nourriture donc autrement
dit nous sommes b et comme les poupées
battait nous avons des tas de gadgets
qui vont avec
par rapport à l'animal quoiqu'il y en a
relativement peu et donc tout d'un coup
une espèce vivante à développer de
manière exponentielle
une technologie très primitif chez
l'animal et la question c'est de savoir
pourquoi est-ce que ça une finalité
alors c'est pas parce que dieu lui
aspirer ça parce que c'est normal et je
veux dire que quand vous prenez les
évolutions belgique et bien vous voyez
apparaître dans l'espérance de 1000 r d
a dit d'aminé donc les briques du vivant
et c'est pas parce que à dieu décide que
ces briques arrive simplement elles sont
probables dans qu'elle existe et a pas
quelques jeux se fait que l'émergence va
donner ce concept de vivant et pour moi
l'univers est une machine pensante
vivante qui cherche à étendre son champ
relationnel c'est sa phénoménologie est
bon le concept de dieu la pub rend
intéressant alors simplement quand on a
cette perspective on est très sociale
c'est à dire que moi je
je n'adhère pas avec ses visions
indienne du genre il faut chercher à
mettre pour se réaliser
je vois c'est toujours centrée sur la
personne pour comment dire épuré son son
mental brossé chez chakra etc
mais qu'est ce que vous faites des
copains voilà et je dirais que les gens
arrivent à d état méditatif qui dorment
donne certainement un état de conscience
différents bon c'est jouissif
ça y est vous avez une jouissance mais
en faisant ça est-ce que ils sont pas en
train d'anticiper leur propre mort c'est
terrible comme idée c'est que justement
quand on voit ces gens avec leurs belles
robes couleur lie de vin qui vous parle
de voix que l'idée c'est d'avoir une
mansuétude complète de considérer le
genre humain grand sourire mais nous
sommes nous sommes très solidaires
moi je me sens responsable de tout ce
qui se passe sur terre globale que je
trouve actuellement indispensable il
faut que nous percevions comme une
espèce global on ne peut pas considérer
que le voisin est un ennemi c'est pas
possible
cette fois c'est hyper technique c'est
un dépassement de finalité est idiot
nous avons des armes pour détruire un
fille c'est con mais il faut indiquer
aux pipes une bâton mais surtout moi je
suis convaincu que notre technologie et
à la veille d'un changement de paradigme
qui va nous amener à manipuler les
transmutation voyez il ya eu un
phénomène formidable en 2006 un article
de mon animal comme as qui est décédé en
2012 qui s'appelait over to bury plus de
2 milliards degrés et voilà que d'un
coup avec une musette machine fabrique
jusqu'à 3 milliards 7 + 3 milliards de
valises en fait alors que dans une
à ta cabane vous monter à 200 millions
un niveau moins et franchement on aurait
dit au genre est ce qu'on pourra un jour
sur trois milliards oui et non seulement
ça mais maintenant on aurait
probablement est à 10 milliards de gray
pourquoi parce que cette machine là n'a
pas de limitation en température la
température atteinte varient comme le
carré du de l'intensité des chutes
si vous mettez le paquet de millions en
terre qui fait et ça si on monte à 1000
milliards de degrés on va commencer à
jouer que les noyaux et si on s'est
orienté st alors pour fabriquer les
atomes et vous ramener commencé comme ça
vous dit tu veux je voudrais du
tungstène
ah bon vous en voulez combien on va
prendre la poussière de votre chemin va
le transformer en tungstène ensuite
enchaîné déchets ces déchets va les
transformer en hélium lança tranquille
lieu de montrer à la hauteur mosphere
sera filmée par le soleil et puis
éventuellement ça c'est un rallye alors
voilà à vendre ou pas de problème de
déchets pas de problème de matières
premières pas de problème d'énergie
on fait tous acceptent la seule chose
qui reste c'est comment nous organiser
au mieux c'est plus la peine d'essayer
de posséder des choses ça n'a plus aucun
sens oui nous imagine la rivière de
diamants déjà avec les fouilles
artificiel le fait de se promener avec
les peau de panthère salaire un peu
l'idiot mais là c'est s'aider vrai quoi
jeudi un des vrais diamants
vous pouvez les détester par
cristallographie ils ont exactement la
nature
donc pourquoi en posséder cet idiot et
sa philosophiquement c'est extrêmement
important
le philosophe c'est pas quelqu'un qui
doit réfléchir sur son qu'ils soient à
lui qu'est ce que je vais devenir et moi
moi moi très bien écouter jean bien je
vous propose peut-être de conclure wes
cet entretien vraiment très très
intéressant sur sur la philosophie la
métaphysique et puis y sommes allés au
delà un petit peu de du modèle
scientifique est ce que vous auriez un
message à faire passer à nos spectateurs
nous auditeurs
une bouteille à la mer comme dirait
l'autre voilà je vous laisse le mot de
conclusion disant que quand j'étais prof
à la fac d'aix
on va demander de faire des cours de
sciences au philosophe donc je me suis
retrouvé dans ce monde là avec des
idiotes philosophie qui était quatre
fois plus à dit moi j'ai ces gens là
m'ont appris dans band seront donc doit
être c'est vrai tout d'un coup moi je
sortais d'études scientifiques
j'avais fait l'école supérieure
d'optique jamais été ingénieur en
aéronautique tout d'un coup j'arrivais
sur des philosophes qui me rappelait qui
dit vous savez il ya un type simple
aristote il a dit ceci c'était vers lui
et donc j'ai découvert un monde
chatoyant comme si c'est complètement
fou qu'on puisse arriver à ses études de
sciences sans avoir fait le moindre
atome date homme de défi donc bien là
sont d'ailleurs rien à ce moment alors
vous avez des scientifiques qui font des
philosophes arabes comme disait à un
étudiant à l'heure où la métaphysique
est en crise il y avait souvent de voir
que la philosophie de bistrot se porte
bien
il ya beaucoup de chinois subissent trop
peut-être que ce que je dis aussi ses
fils une fille de bistrot mais on
aimerait à une sorte de rencontres avec
des philosophes parce que je suis
maintenant c'est terminé quand je vais à
la fac de lettres il ya plus mais dans
le temps ils sont tous morts mais colas
qu'ils offrent
c'est des gens pourris la philosophie
c'est à ça permet de parler de tout
alors quand vous dites un message et
c'est dur de parler de tout à travers et
je pense qu'on a commencé aujourd'hui
donc j'espère qu'on nous en bretagne pas
la sienne aujourd'hui repose y aller
couper
[Musique]
le goût de la fin c'est à main il est
parfait